So, let's just go through these answers 1 by 1 to figure out which ones are
correct. Starting off with 2z, we see that this is something that is multiplied
by 5x and by 7y in order to equal this term. So, this is definitely a radiance
here. Now when we look at 5, we need to remember, again. Invisible
multiplication sign between the 5 and the x. If we multiply 5 by x and 7y and
2z, then we get this whole term. So 5 is also a factor. Now 1 is where things
get a little bit tricky and if you miss this one Not a big deal. This actually
is a factor of this term, and actually, of any term. The reason that 1 is a
factor for any term we might have, whether it's a number or a variable, is
because if you multiply 1 by that term itself, you will end up with the term
that you're looking for. So in our case, the thing that we need to multiply 1
by, in order to get 5x times 7y times 2z is just this term itself. I know that
might seem a little bit complicated right now, but you'll have plenty of
practice in the upcoming quizzes, to sort this all out. Bottom line, 1 is always
a factor. Now at first you might think that 0 is similar to 1 in this way. But 0
is actually not a factor here. We can't divide this expression by 0. That would
actually give us a solution that we don't know how to interpret right now. And
there's nothing that we can multiply by 0 in order to get this expression, since
0 times anything is just equal to 0. So, 0 should not be checked off. We know
that y is multiplied by 7. And also by 5X and 2Z to come up with this term. So
we should check that one off as well, and X works in the same way so we've
checked everything off except for the 0. That was great, I know that factors are
alittle bit trickier than terms so I hope that this vocabulary is starting to
make a little bit more sense. We'll keep using it really frequently.